أعتقد فقط أن حقيقة
أنني مستهدف بشكل مكثف يعني أن
ما نقوم به من أجل فلسطين هو
أننا نحظى بدعم
العالم وهذه محاولات يائسة لمحاولة
إيقافنا ، فهناك الكثير من المنظمات التي
تقف وراءنا.
حملات التشهير الأخيرة التي كنت
أواجهها وحملات التشهير التي
واجهتها منذ أن أصبحت
طالبًا في القانون وحتى قبل أي
طالب فلسطيني ، غالبًا ما يتم استهداف أي مؤيد للفلسطينيين في الولايات المتحدة من
قبل
المنظمات الصهيونية عبر الإنترنت التي تحاول
تقويض عملنا.  ولكن تم
نقل هذا إلى مستوى جديد عندما
تحدثت عضوة مجلس مدينة نيويورك إينا فيرنيكوف وإريك
بينوفيتز مؤخرًا عن قانون كونى نفسه
الجامعة التي ذهبت إليها
وحقيقة أنني كنت متحدثًا للتخرج هناك
[موسيقى]
أنا مستهدف لأنني  إنهم يعلمون
أن حديثي ليس مجرد شيء
يقتصر علي الحديث عن فلسطين
ليس مجرد شيء تعرف أن
الفلسطينيين يدعمونه فقط ولكن الكثير من
الأشخاص الآخرين يدعموننا.  د لهذا السبب تم
اختياري لأكون المتحدث في
الفصل الدراسي لتخرج عام 2022 لأن
زملائي كانوا يعرفون
أنني سأتحدث عن فلسطين وأنني سأتحدث عن
قرار bds الذي مررناه
وجميع التغييرات التي تمكنا من القيام بها  مكسب
وصنع في مدرسة القانون في cuny وفي
جميع أنحاء مدينة نيويورك ، أنا ممتن
لكم جميعًا وأعلم أنه بدونكم
لن أكون هنا
في الواقع ، كانت هناك لحظات عديدة في
السنوات الثلاث الماضية حيث اعتقدت أنني لم
أكن '  لن أفعل ذلك
فقد كنت أواجه حملة مضايقات صهيونية من
قبل منظمات ممولة تمويلًا جيدًا
لها علاقات بالحكومة والجيش الإسرائيليين
على أساس هويتي الفلسطينية وتنظيمي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[  الموسيقى]
أعضاء مجلس المدينة هم جزء من
حكومة مدينة نيويورك بشكل أساسي
الذين يضيعون وقتهم في محاولة
لمنع الفلسطينيين من التحدث
عن اضطهادنا ومن أن تكون
حملات
[الموسيقى] المناهضة للصهيونية
قد أثرت علينا دائمًا.
لأن ذلك يجعل من الصعب
علينا النضال من أجل تحرير فلسطين عندما
يتعرض مستقبلنا المهني وأمننا للتهديد المستمر
في الواقع ، فأنت تعلم أنني لم
أتأثر فعلاً بهؤلاء الصهاينة بطريقة
نجحوا فيها ، كما تعلمون
دفعني لطرد من مدرستي لمدة
ثلاث سنوات بينما كنت هناك ، ليس
فقط أنني لم أطرد مطلقًا ، لقد مررت
بقراري bds وكنت المتحدث في الفصل ،
لذا فقد أدى ذلك إلى نتائج عكسية
[موسيقى]